yeah it's like this I was playing death
stranding then I realized I could just
take a break from death stranding play
Jedi fall in order and beat it in the
time it would take me to get 10% farther
in deaths training so I did that
so here's video
[Music]
so Jedi fallen orders the new Star Wars
game developed by Respawn Entertainment
also published by EA which means through
EA's dismay I'm sure there are no loot
boxes microtransactions in here a pure
single-player Star Wars game you play as
a young guy former Padawan his name's
Cal he was just a kid when order 66
happened he's been hiding out on this
junk planet then in the scene that kind
of reminded me of a scene from x-men
apocalypse the Empire kind of gets wind
like the former Jedi force user alright
let's go after so the inquisitors are
coming after you you team up with this
crew of misfits on a ship and go on your
adventure an adventure that's pretty
much yes a frankenstein hodgepodge taken
from a few other games formed together
to make a frankenstein of a new game but
it feels fun first of all i love the
story it's a good personal story as well
as a grand scope story i heard the story
was epic and at first i was like it was
a good personal story but not halfway
through the game so uh yeah there's the
epic i thought i had some good tions one
in particular i was like great he didn't
overcook it in this game i'm glad i'm
glad that that character kind of got a
mulligan but as for the gameplay like I
said the gameplay does borrow from a lot
of other games it has that Uncharted
vibe when exploring you're climbing up
walls though it was really weird it
makes you have to grab on to the vines
when you jump onto a wall full of vines
that clearly is there to climb you have
to push l2 to grab onto the vines
otherwise the computer will be like oh I
thought you wanted to drop to your death
okay alright we'll make you grab the
vine so you can climb so I had the
climbing and exploring of uncharted yeah
not quite as good as Uncharted on that
front and the fact that it throws in
that Metroidvania element you're like
can't get there yet
gonna find an ability which I can then
I'll come back and I can get there and
then I can find new things Metroidvania
is just one of those it's one of those
systems it's one of those formats and
formulas that just always works for me
keeps it linear enough to keep you on
track but then branches out when you hit
new abilities I am gonna gripe a little
bit about the outfit I mean his baseline
his starter outfits actually pretty cool
so I just kept that but you unlock
ponchos like I ever asked for a Jedi to
wear ponchos the Poncho's were lame in
compared to the starter outfit he had I
was just like why would I wear the
Poncho's as opposed to I'll just keep
the starter outfit so anytime I found a
treasure chest and it had a poncho and
it just felt like a waste you get to
customize the hilt of your lightsaber
that's fun but really uncommon
it reminds me of MORTAL KOMBAT 11 but
it's like you get to customize the belt
it's like yeah but when I'm fighting I'm
not like ooh the belt don't even notice
those finer details when it's all going
down I will say the combat oh it's yeah
it's tough a couple of strong troopers
can kill you which is weird because you
think about it you're like yeah but I'm
a Jedi before its user I should just
stomp those stormtroopers so you're not
actually a Jedi you're a former Padawan
who hasn't used the Force in a few years
you were a kid when you stopped you're
not gonna be an unstoppable force you're
not gonna be the best Jedi ever and
actually really like that about the game
again at first and there's a lot of at
first at first I felt this then I kind
of leaned into it at first I was like I
felt so much more badass in the Force
Unleashed also with the force unleash
the combat got boring because you stomp
everything at a point you can look you
can wipe out a fleet of stormtroopers in
like a second in that game this game not
so much but that does keep it engaging
and like I said yeah it's tough at a
point I got patterns down I was like
okay and then I ran across this other
enemy that I was like okay rage quit I
just got to put it down for a day and
yes you can tweak the difficulty you can
make it easier or harder at any point in
the game and just personal suggestion
this is just me there's just my
experience with the game if you need to
bust the difficulty down to story mode
do that if you just need to get past a
new enemy maybe you just need to learn
the patterns before you take this enemy
on again sometime maybe it's just this
ball numbing ly difficult situation that
you just need to get past okay cool
however don't leave it on story mode for
too long because you're compromising
what the game is in a combat can be
frustrating it can lead to rage quit for
me sometimes the rage quits for like
it's the load times in between deaths
are like a minute I mean it doesn't
sound like much but when you're in the
middle of combat and then you stare at
the wall for a minute it seems like
forever it might have patched it since I
don't know point is I'm just saying if
you want to experience the game as
intended if you bust down the difficulty
to story mode do it enough for you to
take a breath and then pump it back up
to Jedi Knight because people are very
adaptable and you will adapt either way
keep it on Jedi Knight mode and you will
adapt to at the right moment block
counter dodge strike attack at the right
time but bust it down to story mode too
long and you adapt to just walk through
the hits and just slash dudes down
because really their hits don't take too
much damage from you because that's what
I did I'm totally
kind of front I got rage pissed and I
was like alright you know what I'm just
gonna bust it down to story mode and
play that I played it on story mode and
then at a point I was like this game's
too easy it's not fulfilling oh yeah it
is on story mode then you try to go to
Jedi Knight mode after playing story
mode for hours in the words of the great
Illidan play it how you like but that's
my experience if you put it on story
mode for too long it's like if you put
on a story mode for too long you kind of
gotta ride it out now as for some of the
technical [ __ ] and there is
technical [ __ ] in here Who am I
kidding there's not a couple times you
walk into a new seems like the graphics
those like that why does it look like
muddy [ __ ] ah okay it just took a
bit to render right in front of me like
hey guys what's up how's it going
alright we just did that thing back
there just see that alright we're moving
out of cache Sheik the worst world in
the game oh hey look at that we look
good again okay so let's leave Kashyyyk
the muddy forest water planet slug [ __ ]
of Star Wars games sorry wasn't a fan of
Keshi and a couple times when I got into
a new area it froze and had to load and
catch up and it just takes you out of it
you know it takes away from the flow of
the game flow of the experience if you
don't think it does trust me
totally does in terms of the combat I
enjoyed the combat because it's all
about the block the counter using the
force and then strike which also use
your forest powers you will gain them
back there's no sense in holding off to
your force use them when you want also
stem packs use that as well whenever you
hit a Meditation spot and then you rest
you get them back so no point in holding
on to stuff just use it I feel like with
the combat it was a little more slow and
methodical from your side I mean some of
these enemies are pretty intense but for
you you have to block counter dodge hit
it's not as fast as you might expect
from a Star Wars game involving a
lightsaber and a farz user which makes
sense story wise and it wouldn't bother
me as much if I got more to work with
you unlock a few forest moves a few
moves you do and a couple of buttons in
tandem you know like dodge attack but it
could have gone for having a bit more in
terms of combos and light saber attacks
per lightsaber build you get three
different lightsaber builds but really
your single bladed lightsaber that's
your main it's not like in God of War
you have three distinct builds with
three trees of abilities in fallen order
your single bladed lightsaber that's the
one you use the most you get a double
bladed lightsaber at a point it works
well against multiple enemies and
deflecting a lot of blaster bolts back
to enemies then at a point you get two
lightsabers and you think oh that's
gonna be my main but it's not you push
l1 while you're attacking with your
lightsaber and he'll split it and he'll
do one move I was just kind of
disappointed the fact that you have
three lightsaber builds so really you
don't have three tiers three trees of
moves it felt like a wasted opportunity
in which they could have done so much
more with the lightsaber builds doesn't
change the fact that if you are playing
Jedi Knight mode or higher you learn the
patterns you take him down you feel
pretty badass but you do get some fun
force ability it's just so good like
freeze flap yeah that's you down a cliff
I actually did I swear to you
audibly in my living room I actually
said this out loud there were a group of
stormtroopers I jumped down right into
the middle of them I stood up and I went
hello that it was amazing to do but I
also like the fact I'm just telling you
what doesn't happen in this game you
don't ever have that big toe-to-toe
battle with Darth Vader or anything just
wouldn't make sense to have this kid
against Darth Vader and it really does
show how scary and powerful Darth Vader
is we just made this kid take
Darth Vader be like our eyes and Darth
Vader's a punk and this is canon but he
took him on it's actually really story
based wise in terms of respecting the
universe of Star Wars I appreciate the
fact that you don't just tow to tow
fight Darth Vader however in the end I
do feel like the ending it felt a little
anticlimactic I don't know if they're
saving it for DLC or possibly the like
hey we'll have a sequel somehow but he
did walk away from this game going huh
all right so so that's dead because in
the end Jedi fall in order I had a great
time with it it's ball crushingly
frustrating at first at least it was for
me I'm not a Dark Souls person I haven't
been forged in the fire so to speak so
when I played this I was like wow okay
this is mmm got to take a breath got to
get used to it but if you can take a
breath and enjoy the slower methodical
fighting style of this game does have
though I mean is fast in the sense that
sometimes they start coming at you
multiple waves of enemies with different
tactics and combat builds but that's
where the puzzle is that's where you
have to go okay how do I check these
guys out what do i do how am I gonna
prioritize it actually does get quite
fun though I do hold to the elements
that they borrow from other games this
game isn't as good at those elements as
the games it borrows from however in its
own right it does build itself a really
enjoyable Frankenstein game that is a
great Star Wars game and I'll say Jedi
fallen order is worth buying at full
price you know I'm liking where we're at
right now we have ourselves a good Star
Wars show we have ourselves a good Star
Wars game I'm liking this alright so
Jedi fallen order have you played it
what do you think of it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more I did that wrong click
right here to see more that's better
[Music]